there have been questions raised about
your your temperament and
your reaction to criticism uh tribune
editorial use the term
erasable uh how much of this do you
think might have to do with the fact
that you're a woman
and partic specifically a black woman
about 99 of it yeah and the other one
percent was too busy getting shot in
your city
[Applause]
[Music]
all right another great show tonight
julie banderas is back
which is pretty amazing given
yesterday's boat tripod
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but at least you dried out i did i mean
your clothes
michael loftus is here and as usual
as usual he looks like he got dressed in
the dark at a homeless shelter
[Laughter]
stole boxcar willie's jacket
but he's having a great summer if only
he and his buddies could learn to throw
[Music]
frisbee
yeah some friends huh you said you
weren't gonna play that
well it's too late promised me all right
shut up loftus
so we're all happy to be here with you
you know who's not happy
cnn once a destination for news when tv
was in black and white
is now a motley assortment of glum
freaks touting what's left of their
shredded reputation
they act like the former soviet union
clinging to past glory
and full economies it's a clown car
minus the car
so between the first and second quarter
of this year the network has lost
more than half of its audience yeah in
mere months
they went from six people trapped in an
airport watching don lemon cry
to three and those three
viewers were baggage handlers on break
yeah they're racing to the bottom faster
than brian stelter eating a can of
concentrated tomato paste
it's not elegant but it's tasty their
prime time hours are in free fall
averaging under a million viewers
meanwhile in the daytime it's roughly
650
000 viewers how i get that many viewers
when i do nude pilates on my balcony
reliable sources hosted by captain pop
and fresh
lost 53 of its viewers since january
you know remember his tough question
that jen sackey was asking her how
he could do his job better well that's
easy stop
writing books about fox news and report
the news yes shaved hamster
[Laughter]
no wonder people take him as seriously
as a velcro wallet
since last year cnn lost 49 percent of
total viewers
they're changing their slogan from the
worldwide leader in news
to the most watched news network at
planet fitness
msnbc lost viewers too but not nearly as
much so you can't attribute it to just
generic disinterest
they got hit losing 37 in prime time and
fox lost a little too
which is understandable given a country
reopening coming out of an election
summer arriving slow news brian kilmeade
[Laughter]
but there's something else going on with
cnn they don't have a single show in the
top 20.
who could have predicted this
do you miss me they miss me
[Music]
they miss me i know
they look at their bad ratings and
they're saying we miss this guy
i said it was gonna happen i was waiting
for them to endorse me actually
i know that was a big step but they're
going down the tubes their numbers are
very bad
it's funny because it's true and it's
funny because it's trump
all cnn had going for it were broken
remote controls at grandma's and a
deep hatred for trump and everything
associated with him
from his once 89 million followers on
twitter to the guy who makes his taco
salads
and once their target of hatred left the
white house their only narrative
was orphaned of course they continued
loathing trump supporters but it
just wasn't the same to cnn the white
house without trump was like
one direction without zayn
gonna let that reference sit for a while
see trump was such a big interesting
target that cnn could feed off him like
a giant leech
he was an endless buffet spread of yummy
stories
remove that and you see cnn for what it
is first
unappealing and angry hosts cnn was
karen
before karen even existed
in fact it's unfair to karen's to keep
using that name
negatively when it's really not karen
it's dawn
chris and anderson who were there first
cnn is the one-stop
shaming network they're disapproving
anchors always wagging an
overpaid finger they pass judgment like
a cattle farm passes gas
cnn went from respective news to a
rumor-mongering hate machine
you could say their fomenting of racial
strife helped destroy cities
you could say they have more blood on
their hands than hannibal lecter after
lunch
you could say that but i won't
[Laughter]
because i'm not that type of guy but
also cnn's obsession with trump
led to butt loads of errors from
collusion to kavanaugh lafayette square
the wuhan lab
hands up don't shoot avenatti russia
russia russia
they walked back more tails than a
tuxedo delivery service
[Music]
yeah that was bad huh but their strategy
was always to pivot from one trump tale
to another
now that he's gone so goes that strategy
meanwhile the same time we saw cnn
collapse
something else was going on gutfeld
was the number one cable news show in
total viewers
for the hour
yes
but get this get this fact
at 11 o'clock we surpass every cnn show
in every hour every hour in total
viewers
think about that this little spunky show
at 11 p.m is beating all their shows in
prime time
that's not like david beating goliath
it's david beating goliath and then
marrying his sister so you have to see
him every thanksgiving
this show also toppled some long-running
alleged comedy shows on the broadcast
networks including both
jimmy's not a bad start for what the
legacy media had branded a certain
failure
they wanted us to fail so bad because
they're miserable people
the failed comedians the unhappy blog
writers the blue check gawkers on
twitter
they needed this show not to work
because they weren't working either
but now the numbers are in and we
crushed it and weirdly they've gone
quiet
but it's not over yet i'm not ready to
have the last laugh
i just enjoy the fact that we're all
laughing we're having a good time
we don't talk down to the viewers well
let's be honest i can't talk down to
anyone
but we aren't interested in dividing
people we don't tell family members to
inform on liberals
or try to de-platform cnn we want you to
go to bed feeling hope and not hopeless
and we don't think the other side is
evil we just think they're wrong
and human but they think we're evil and
that's the lesson
a network built on hate is failing but a
show
built on love is thriving
i mean look at the love that we show
each other
tyrus i'm glad you uh got dressed today
you're not a clean person are you
you're a dirty star judge you don't care
you're so rich
steve uh welcome to the show i gather
you just got off a charity fun run
greg you really blew that set up what is
snobbery define
snobbery um you got a mirror jim you are
white
and i would say probably a jerk right
morgan um i hope you left your
motorcycle out back it's hard because
you don't have many friends to begin
with
so did your friend circle shrink to like
minus six jimmy it looks like you
actually mugged liberace's
closet with that jacket yeah abby
welcome to the show i just want to warn
you this isn't like fox nation where you
can just use the f word whenever you
want let's keep going you know with to
that point
uh you're back crazy i was gonna bring
this up to you julie because you have
children which is a scary thought you
know loftus
once again i'm glad that you're not
you're refusing to get dressed up for
this show
i know that last night you were probably
in some hotel room bombed out of your
skull
you barely knew where you were you fox
and friends elitists
right with your curvy couches and your
cooking segments that you could come up
in here
lucky for you you're a shut-in you don't
go out very often it's true no cat
before you got married you were filthy
you never went to bed this weekend did
you you just came straight from the club
you know love
and maybe our success and sensitivity
can teach cnn something
maybe they'll look at gutfeld and go you
know what he's more than just a pretty
face
he's also very short
tonight's ghost
she's saucier than an explosion at a
ragu factory
fox zeus channel anchor julie maduros
he's the former ag who can bench press
you and me
former acting attorney general matt
whitaker
when homeless people see him they give
him spare change
the loftistparty.com editor-in-chief
michael loftus
and they call her a bottle blonde
because she brought stoli to her hair
appointment
focus contributor cat tip
julie uh quite impressive uh start for
this show
feel free you're welcome yes thank you
yes yes feel free to compliment me and
my success
share me with praise or just shower me
well i think every time that i've come
on your ratings have been great
congratulations that's true that's i'm
very proud of you especially you've
really come a far away from not being
able to read teleprompter
back when you started red eye to like
gloriously going through a three-hour
intro there
without stumbling once which is quite
frankly a miracle yeah no it's a
surprise that i can't even do
i could even talk no i'm actually really
impressed you've come far away yes yes
what do you see matt is the future for
cable news because it seems to me that
they're in a
downward spiral except for fox of course
we're on an upward spiral
i just coined that phrase yeah well we
we have now reached a point
in our society where this is
entertainment the news is entertainment
that's what trump kind of bridged right
and now
sleepy joe biden is not entertaining us
the american people are turning it off
yeah and that's what and that's why
you're seeing your show as great as it
is
when we're on this show it's better
but but it's entertainment politics is
now entertainment and that's what the
american people look for and that's what
you're giving them
that's what fox news is delivering too
yeah you know the thing about fox that
is different than cnn is that
we're actually people yeah wait
no i mean like like it's cnn cnn or just
they're all
variations cnn are all variations of
one person but fox is all different
people we're like
and so that people develop relationships
with people on this network and feel
like they know them
uh and that is different than when you
turn on cnn and everybody's just a
different version of anderson cooper
and yes you're putting your finger to
your mouth like you have a thought
it's almost like it's fox and friends
um
michael um we're going to get to the
bestiality segment in the eat
don't jump ahead um
you think i'm kidding that's what you
call a long tease
but we are going to do that story no the
other thing too is that i think that
once
um once trump started
hammering the phrase fake news which
wasn't a new idea because we were always
talking about bias in the news
but once it was coming from the white
house and that he was doing it every day
it changed the media who then had to
defend itself but couldn't
the whole thing is wonderful like the
success of this show
is truly wonderful it's a reminder that
we're not
crazy yes because for years and years
and years you think wow all these
stories lean to the left they all lean
to the left they lean
and then you're like okay so i'm not
crazy and when trump was elected the
masks came off
and cnn they were they were just like
trump junkies
yeah you know and they turned a big part
of the country those poor people who
would watch
cnn and like really believe it every day
and just like oh today's the day
they're going to get it yes the walls
are closing the walls are closing in
there's poor people just the adrenaline
rush after a there's like
they're not watching cnn because they're
collapsed in a bathroom sobbing and just
rocking themselves
it's horrible i mean you know that that
feeling intimately
i do i'm just happy that you've almost
cleaned yourself up
yeah you know it is interesting that cnn
okay so we everybody uses the phrase
karen and it is unfair to women named
karen because
it's just it's almost bigoted but cnn is
more like gladys
from bewitched remember gladys was the
next door neighbor and
constantly consumed hated hated
hated the bewitched family but was
consumed by them i'm talking about
something that
happened before a cat's birth i was
gonna say you're gonna have to use a
different cultural reference because of
my youth it's a nose
they're like the nosy neighbor that that
is obsessed with you
oh and so they're kind of they hate you
hate you hate you but they're like brian
stelter's reliable sources
is about fox news yes it's always about
fox news nothing else
where do you see this going young lady
i'd like to say you you deserve partial
credit
for the success of this show but i'll
leave that up to the viewers
no you had to and i understand but also
everyone like he didn't have to bring me
along on this
journey as they call it on the bachelor
in the bathroom right yes
i think it's awesome um i think it's
great that we
talk about stuff that other people don't
talk about not everybody has the exact
same point of view on this show
and like you said we're com you know
starting with this and we're ending the
show with bestiality you won't see that
on cnn
no you won't and in between we're going
to talk about
yeah that's true
by the way i mean the story in the
e-block is is is
an interesting debate that is raging in
social media
and it but it happens to evol involve a
woman making out with a dog
which is there's nothing wrong with that
i'm a former prosecutor
but actually i think in every state it's
banned
let's just do the show in reverse let's
just go ahead and find define me
i can't believe we're talking about this
in the a block i'm really
excited for it my whole life has led up
to this e-block
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else